hi is that colin yes it is hi bobby it's
gordon hi gordon
bobby yeah i'm pissed off
yeah
i have to eliminate two restaurants from
this competition
when i saw those plates getting put
down to the wrong position i got so
frustrated because i kind of screamed
then you've got that level of support in
the dining room it should be absolute
perfection
you've already shot
up until now
and you have to
focus
in that restaurant on a daily basis
when she can feel
is leaving the competition
okay
i'm sorry right
because i know we are
you know
so much better than that but that's
consistency for you you need to be
you know bang on every time all the time
right now
you need to focus
because you're going through to the next
stage
bobby i will never ever let you down
again congratulations thank you thank
you so much thank you bye-bye
they need to focus now
and he's been given a lifeline
and the restaurant
across the board is too good to leave
this competition
two fantastic restaurants remained both
desperate for a place in the final now
i've got a big shop for them